[Music]
resident evil 7 released on january
twenty fourth and now we know exactly
how many copies cap comes to rival
horror game has shipped so far I'm Matt
and this is your horrifying gamespot
news updates according to capcom
resident evil 7 has shipped 2.5 million
copies of course that just means that
the number of copies capcom has sold
into stores and unfortunately it's not
clear of digital sales factor into this
number the exact number sold through two
customers is also unknown as for the
latest entries in the series resident
evil 5 racked up 7.1 million copies
while r is an evil 6 reach 6.6 million
there among the best-selling games in
the series but it's important to
remember that they've had much longer
lives on the market than resident evil 7
the company expects the seventh game the
series to sell 4 million by March 31st
resident evil 7 received a score of 8
out of 10 in our review GameSpot Scott
Butterworth said that it has a clear
vision and execute it with impressive
patience and precision by returning to
horror resident evil has once again
become something special for more on
Capcom's horror series and the world
video games stay tuned to GameSpot's